hello everyone I'm really happy that so
many people found the topic interesting
it's a bit intimidating because it's
also my first talk at the PI data
conference but anyway yeah a long long
time ago about six months actually in an
office far away on Alexander flat switch
from he is actually kind of far my team
and I we had a problem we had a problem
because we found ourselves in the
station where we had to implement
machine learning research papers how
many of you can relate to this problem
so how many of you have eaten uni or on
work tried to implement machine learning
papers that's a lot of people and how
many of you found that power system was
frustrating or annoying or a bit
confusing keep your hands up that's
still a lot of people so my background
is actually less of machine learning and
it used to be more data engineering and
analytics and so for a long time I've
avoided looking into machine learning
research paper I saw there would be
filled with really unpredictable us and
very impractical suggestions but then
work is all about growth right so
eventually you have to do even the
things that you find scary and
fortunately I was not alone some of my
colleagues from that time I actually
here in that room and we we all had
worked with research some time in our
time at uni writing teasers writing
journal papers whatever and so we pulled
all of our knowledge together about how
to approach this problem and our use
case project it's what's called page
stream separation so we found us in the
situation that we wanted to classify
documents and we found ourselves with
the situation where we were able to
document classify the documents pretty
reliably but on the other hand we also
wanted to break the multi-page talk
multi document PDFs into separate
documents so you have a stream of pages
and you want to figure out which of them
is the ID which one is the income
statement which one is the contract and
that's what this is one of the papers we
use I'll Eustace refer to this paper a
few times in the talk but then of course
the question is when should you actually
bother with implementing machine
learning papers
the one condition in my mind that really
needs to be hurt us you have this idea
it's not something that nobody has ever
tried before somebody else mastered
solve this issue before but then on the
other hand nobody has well somebody
might have solved the problem nobody has
ever made a ready-made implementation
something that you can take and go and
either buy or just install and so then
you find yourself with somebody
hopefully wrote down what they did but
in the form of research paper but nobody
ever implemented it and that's exactly
the situation we found ourselves and we
found a lot of tooling to help us with
classifying documents but nothing to
separate the stream of documents into
separate documents and so then pooling
all our knowledge together this is the
kind of a cleaned up version of the
process we came up with and followed and
that to give a bit of a spoiler to my
issue that I had in the beginning it
actually wasn't as bad as I thought it
was actually in many places quite
enjoyable and so I hope that I'll see
you did find a experience frustrating
before that following similar process
might make it a bit easier and then you
can focus more on the details of what
you're doing and less on organizing your
workflow and the first step in this
workflow is to look for research finding
that's abdi of your starting point
because you need to start with something
then once you have a pile of papers or
at least the list of papers or something
figure out which ones are the right for
you based on with the coat areas and so
the key so in this step you just define
which criterias make a good paper for
you and then the core of the process is
evaluating the papers and figuring out
which paper based on the criteria you
have is the best one and then after you
have the pro a list of papers that you
find relevant to your own problem
prioritize them to figure out which one
to start with and only the last stop
step is actually the actual of building
a prototype and for the rest of my talk
I want to describe those steps in a bit
more detail yeah so the first step so
when you look into the problem we had we
just paid segmentation
you get about 2 million hits in Google
Scholar which is obviously not something
that you would ever want to look at in
all detailing it's all comprehensiveness
so what we have to do is build some kind
of map of the universe or of the amount
of papers in this area and figure out
which of the ones are right for us and
you may remember if you've wrote the
thesis in uni or something or a research
paper it's a similar problem actually
and probably you're your adviser gave
you Teresa the idea to compile an
overview of the field does may even have
been your only assignment if it was a
seminar paper and then you find the best
way to usually start with doses somebody
has already compiled at least a part of
the research universe for you usually
not completely but there are papers that
summarize a lot of related research in
the field and as you find a few of those
or maybe you even find the textbook
chapter if you're really lucky you can
follow the references of those papers
and then there are two things that are
really interesting to look at as you
build your understanding of the field to
figure out which is the the main meat of
the areas one is to figure out what are
the common problems that people are
facing so what are they actually working
on and why are they working on these and
which are the top approaches that people
use so so that when you look into a
paper you don't start with something
that turns out to be really random but
something that's really a major approach
and the papers that are usually
interesting are those that are either
foundational oh that are which means
they started a new approach and form the
different way to solve the problem that
you're facing or they are cutting-edge
which means they took an existing
approach and they're really new and had
a new approach to the issue so now that
that we build this kind of map and we
have a hopefully somewhat comment
commented list of research papers that
we want to look at the next question is
as I said how do we compare them and
that's very really it's you're a lot of
involves a lot of your own crud
creativity because here you're tailoring
your analysis to the specific problem
that you you're facing as opposed to
what whoever else wrote
of their papers and what we didn't
really have fullest first to summarize
the common metrics that other people
have used to address the summit to
evaluate models for the same problem to
come to memorize metrics and also find
some baselines to compare against and
then pick some simple ones that are easy
to evaluate both metrics and baselines
and for the metrics it's also really
important to be clear about what's the
best a minimum level that you need to
achieve in your problem to file it
actually make sense in your context
maybe that 70% if you're happy with a
really vague answer but maybe it's 99.9
percent and that makes a big difference
about which papers you can actually
evaluate or not and there's a link here
which will have some really interesting
explanations about how baselines work if
you want a bit of a refresher like
lurking random data slides slides will
be available later so you can check the
links if you want and now that we know
what defines a good paper for us the
question is of course how do we find the
papers that actually are good for us and
there's a blog article which addresses a
similar similar issue to my talk which I
also linked later in my slides and he
defines three different kinds of papers
that make up the universe of written
papers and he says one of them is the
groundbreaking papers those which are
like the foundational papers are
referenced earlier which define a new
approach to solving the problem that
you're facing then there's what he calls
copycat papers which i think is a bit of
a mean name but he is pretty negative
about them is that those are papers that
take an existing approach and try to
improve it I think that's actually a
nice thing but he his argument is that
they often complicate the approach more
than necessary which is something to
consider
so the the capital purpose they try to
improve their approach and they'd a
succeed or not but they sometimes they
also simplify their existing foundation
of paper and then unfortunately as you
probably all have seen their pay
thus that were just published for the
sake of publishing which don't really
contribute anything to the research
landscape and now of course the question
is how do you find out which papers
actually are good for the purpose that
you want to solve and there are some
obvious binders like a journal and the
conference quality if you can evaluate
that so that's usually a good indicator
and also if you usually if you look a
bit into the teams if you have time to
go there you can see how much teams the
research team has actually worked but
it's your whether it's a one-off paper
for them or whether they have spent 20
years evaluating researching that
particular problem and and to go a bit
deeper into them those two pointers I
have developed a checklist of how to
even which based on the different
sections that are usually in the paper
at least the ones that are particularly
interesting in the evaluation phase and
I want to now present you the checklist
about what to watch out for in a
research paper to find out whether it's
a good paper that you want to prototype
or not and the first section that's
always interesting to check is the
abstract in the introduction that's
usually pretty short so it's not a lot
of time invested and the main question
years is this paper at all relevant to
your problem and there are different
questions you can ask yourself - first
one being does it address your problem
at all or is it about something totally
different that's kind of obvious but a
bit more Sadler's the question does it
address your problem in a similar
context so for example we have here in
this paper we have - the problem is to
separate a stream of scanned image in a
multi-page document this is exactly the
problem we had so in that sense the
paper is probably very relevant and the
context is digital mail rooms or retro
digitalization of light purple sex
digital may around us a bit related to
what we're doing not quite but the other
context is pretty different so it's a
bit of a question mark whether the paper
even though they have a similar problem
whether we can really transfer the
insights from
the paper and then of course there are
questions about the approach again it
was a ground working ban or is it an
improvement and of course looking at the
results are they're better than the
metrics targets and the baselines that
you defined for yourself so if it was
even looking deeper and once you decide
that you want to look deeper and in this
case we decided to look deeper into this
paper the next question is is the
approach reproducible at all so will you
take be able to get the results from the
paper that they claimed to have and the
first question does the data set size
and content so is it will you be able to
transfer from the day to day use the
Algren take the same algorithm and apply
it to your own use case and going back
to the example paper there the context
and the data set size was reasonably
similar for us so they also had or they
had about twenty thousand like invite
pages which was what we also had what we
had a few put more papers pages but it
was in the same ballpark and the corpus
of the German language was as rare a
research paper and was definitely very
helpful to us and about the context as I
said was different so they used research
documents which have a different
structure than the banking documents
that we were dealing with but still it
it was still worth considering then the
next big question is do they describe
the entire process if they're missteps
and only talk about the things that they
found academically interesting then the
papers really have to reproduce it might
be interesting from the scientific
context but definitely not easy to
implement and as and especially in this
context what is what people like to
admit is pre-processing
even that's really important if you want
to reproduce a paper so in our paper
they seem to have described the entire
process as far as we could tell and in
the pre-processing steps they gave some
information which helped us to get a
date and to the right chefs but it
wasn't quite complete so they did
describe the image convert
and and the scaling so how they dealt
with the pages and images but they had a
multi approach which was both based on
images and on text and for the text I
used OCR and they just said they used
OCR now fortunately OCR these days is
pretty standard so we decided to not be
bothered with that too much but it's
still a question mark because we might
get very different results if for some
reason all she asked for worse um and
then not a big question is do you
understand can you implement the actual
methods so do they if they use a certain
method for example here they use CNN's
do you know what that is
and if you don't know what it is
something pretty obscure do they
describe what it is and fortunately in
this paper they did data scribe order
the CNN these days is not that obscure
and they'd also described how they
configured figure Ted CNN's so it was
there was a real highlight of this paper
and then so we decided we can probably
represented and then we looked at the
results section
so there the question is can we trust
results are they reliable can we can we
be confident that the paper will
actually have the results that we were
looking for and the first question years
what metrics are they using are they
relevant to our use case and the paper
they used accuracy which for a
classification problem as we looked at
the page stream separation as a
classification problem is a pretty
common one and so we decided to take
that as one of our use case matrixes and
also it's appropriate for the problem
because it's a classification province
is pretty common one as I said there's
the bit more subtle the question though
is the kinetic not just relevant for the
problem like classification but also for
the specific data set and here there's a
bit of a concern because when we talk
about page stream separation what we
have is very imbalanced classes so
usually you have
what happens is you label each page with
whether it's a new page starting a new
document or not and this usually you
have much more pages that are not
starting in your document if you have
long documents then you have documents
that pages that actually start using so
you have really heavily unbalanced
dataset and then accuracy as as we
usually knows and all the really good
metrics to start with they're better
months to look at so that was a concern
but we continue to continue with the
results section and there is the next
question is whether the results are
better than the baseline which we
already checked a bit in deterent of
that into the introduction and yet we
found it's about 0.35 better than our
baseline and we also checked whether it
was better than a metric stories and
there we said a metric tested of 95% and
today claimed 93 percent so it's not
quite there but close enough possibly
but then because it's a pretty new paper
I think it was published at the time we
read it about six months ago nobody had
to review the paper yet if somebody has
reviewed the paper and found it to be a
good paper that's of course saves you a
lot of hassle of evaluating it yourself
so that's a strong indicator but this
paper and what still too new to tell
anything and then a bit of a subtle
point that's easy to forget us when the
algorithm claims an improvement over
somebody else's approach is the question
is how did they analyze that how did I
draw this conclusion that I used
comparable metrics that I use proper
statistical tests to analyze that and
that's something that's easily skipped
in papers because it's a bit annoying
and it might evaluate a lot of the
results and also in this paper they
didn't do any statistical analysis and I
didn't even compare with approaches that
had used the same metric so it's unclear
whether they really had the improvements
that they claimed and if you again if
you want to have some more pointers
about how to evaluate a model use look
at statistical tests to compare
here's some more links that you can look
up later if you want
so after this evaluation which are just
performed as an example for one paper
which of course we did for a lot of
papers the question was we found a bunch
of papers that looked so promising which
ones do we prioritize so
mykola quarry was actually sitting here
she remember this really nice matrix
which is used in product management and
then we sat it in in our conference room
and evaluated all the papers that all
the approaches mode to be more precise
that we wanted to try on this matrix
pitches as an one dimension the amount
of impact you expect for which we used
how much they claimed to improve the
metrics that we wanted to improve as a
proxy and also the amount of effort
which comes from is the is this a
ready-made solution is it something we
understand is it something we have to
learn is it something we have to
implement entirely from scratch and then
we just started all the approaches into
this matrix and what we did then I mean
the traditional recommendation is to
start with the quick wins which ideally
have high impact and low effort of
course those are fairy tales usually but
what you can do is at least find
something that somewhere in the mid
impact and mid effort range and start
with that rather than something that
might be more interesting but a lot more
of a hassle to implement so coming to
that now we finally had our list of I
think it was around four approaches or
five approaches that we wanted to
prototype so we were ready to code yay
what could possibly go wrong
of course a lot of things and here a few
Co recommendations I compiled some of
them we used some of them I only
discovered later what do you take into
account when implementing prototypes and
the first recommendation to start in
early in the process of implementing is
to understand what you're doing and to
really understand what you're doing and
if you don't understand something to
figure it out and then compile and
document somewhere come in a glossary
what you what you're implementing and
also likewise under
that make sure that especially when the
notation is weird and it's a lot of
pseudocode or odd formulas to understand
what each of the men are make sure they
don't have typos or the other oddities
it will will really annoy you later in
the process and then when you're
prototyping it's a I found was it's a
really good idea to start with a high
level language so yes maybe sometimes
you hear result will be faster in
implementation when you start with a low
level language but at this point you're
not even sure what you want to implement
so you just want to optimize for
prototyping speed and use something like
Python or Julia or MATLAB octave or
something to prototype rather than jump
into C or Java
already and then kind of a trivial but
useful thing is to reference when you
implement something which paper you're
implementing and which secretary of it
as a code common and then some more
recommendations this one we didn't do
and it really I think it really hurt us
and I found us in this block code that
I'm just about to link is to when you
start implementing try to implement
their products your prototype under the
same conditions as much as possible as
the research paper that you have using
maybe the same data charges what's
accessible and exactly the same
pre-processing and exactly the same
variation of the algorithm and only if
you see that you can reproduce that and
get similar results to your research
paper only then to modify it to fit on
your own data and your own algorithmic
needs because what we found for example
does a week a lot of their process we
try it well not as good as the ones that
were claimed in the research paper and
it's hard to figure out why this would
be the case if you did never try to
implement exactly what the researchers
did and then something really small but
really useful that also Cori suggested
was to compile all the findings in our
paper all the findings we had in a Excel
spreadsheet or Google spreadsheet just
to see for each of the prototypes we
tried and we tried a lot of variations
and there were no floating around and a
lot of no copied no you could tell
notebooks with which metrics that
exactly give which results so we could
actually track in the end and decide
which one is right and not have to take
to a whole amount of jupiter-mass to
figure out which one was actually good
or not and it's not on my slides but I
did a previous round of this talk at at
the Meetup
and somebody recommended a very simple
thing that could be really useful you if
you get stuck right to the authors of
the paper if you can often they have
email addresses and sometimes they might
even respond which i think was a really
pragmatic and good tip so this is the
blog post that I mentioned several times
it's also here for reference it's very
helpful especially on the implemented
planting section and also in the first
step of such the research phase so just
that was just or the main part of my
talk and just to summarize when would
you want to look for a research paper
first of all it's a problem which you
think somebody has solved before and
also a problem which has you think
somebody has solved before you know
somebody else off before but nobody was
kind enough to implement yet and then
that's a good moment you start going and
then when you find yourself in that
situation the these are the steps that I
would recommend make life a lot easier
to follow them in this order first
search for the research findings then
decide on the comparison criteria to
figure out which make what makes a good
paper for your use case then evaluate
all the papers that you find relevant to
find out which ones are really meeting
those criteria then prioritize out of
those that are seem good which ones are
easy to implement and promising and
finally to prototype the approach yeah
and I hope this by help you make your
prototyping life a bit easier the slides
as I said were between two that think
they'll also end up on the conference
page somewhere so feel free to follow
the links thank you very much
[Applause]
thank salad for this really nice and
interesting and really important talk so
we have some times for questions it's
for the recording
how would you face the problems like
sometimes the hyperparameters are not
mentioned in a lot of people's so how
would you recommend probably the best
way is through actually in that case
write to the authors and figure out if
they can send them to you and if not you
can either try or just ignore the paper
because with the hyper press there are
some ways of course to reconstruct a
hyperparameters and you can try that if
it's not - but also you might just not
get verified I think it falls out on the
incomplete algorithm description some
more questions thank you for the nice
talk
so among the five steps based on your
experience do you have a rough measure
between like zero and 100% time of your
times how did you split all these five
steps especially for the first and third
step because I think that searching and
reading papers will also take sometimes
but prototyping also will need some time
so how do you balance this yeah in our
experience most effort we had to spend
was on prototyping and followed by
reading and evaluating the paper so step
three and five were the most
time-consuming and the other ones
deciding which one to the prioritization
was the fastest one and compiling the
information in the first step and
deciding on the criteria was somewhere
in between I guess it's the fifth one is
the most tank of two in charge first and
then the second and the fourth one if
you want to really rank them hello thank
you for your talk I would like to ask
what from your perspective he says just
could do to ease your work sorry what
researchers okay people I think papers
can do to ease your work to make it more
easy that's a really nice question I
appreciate it I think the most important
thing is really to
compliance it described completely what
you're doing and ideally also if you
have an implementation publish it and
maybe put a link somewhere in there in
the intersection that would make a lot
make a lot things easier so ideally you
publish something and if code and if you
cannot or don't want to put publish the
code at least make a describe completely
what you've been doing so that it's
easier to implement on our own thank you
for your talk I have a small question I
mean you use that you mentioned that you
going to check for reviews of a paper
where would you do that I mean some
platforms or can you maybe comment on
that yeah I'm usually the easiest way I
found to find reviews is to search
Google Scholar and they have a set set
weather where there's reference papers
that use this references paper and
usually the papers that reference the
paper some of them have reviews of the
papers hello thank you it's great
presentation I was wondering during the
the compiling of all the papers you
mentioned that you will like pick up the
the metrics to use the information about
the paper are you doing have any
spreadsheet there any structure to do
that anything to help you or or how do
you for example collect the different
papers and share it among the colleagues
yeah yeah we had a Google document and
we just put all the papers in there and
our comments on them and that worked
okay there's more fancy words like
living using something like Mandalay I
guess I don't know which of them are
multi user friendly but for us we just
used the Google Doc that was okay how
big was the percentage of papers that
you started to prototype where you could
not get the same results that they
claimed I think it was at least 80% of
not more it was most definitely most of
them I don't remember the exact details
but was really hard to reproduce the
details in prototyping
how much time did the whole process take
and total and what was basically the end
result yeah so I left somewhere in the
middle of the project I changed up so I
can say exactly the ends Korea's here
she can probably tell you more she's
waving so when I was acting we spent
several months like two three months and
we went up to a band develop a bunch of
prototypes none of which turned out to
be really what we were looking for so
then the team went on and tried some
other approaches which were more present
promising I heard